let's do a few more examples of thinking
of strategies for dividing decimals in
the future we're going to come up with a
more systematic way of doing it but it's
really important to to come up with some
of these strategies because it gives you
an intuition for dividing decimals and
frankly it's an easier thing to do
especially when you're trying to
eventually divide decimals in your head
so let's say we want to figure out what
6
divided
by
0.2 or 2 10 is pause the video and see
if you can figure it out
so we've already explored multiple
strategies one strategy is well let's
express this as a fraction this is the
same thing as 6
over
0.2
and maybe we can multiply the numerator
and the denominator by some value so
we're not dealing with decimals anymore
and if you want to get rid of the
decimal on the bottom we have two tenths
well we can multiply the bottom by 10.
but if we multiply the bottom by 10 we
need to multiply the numerator by 10 so
it's essentially we're multiplying this
fraction times 10 10 which is just
multiplying it by one so it doesn't
change its value
so this is going to be equal to
60 so 6
0
over 2 10 times 10 that's going to move
the decimal 1 to the right and that's
just going to be equal to 2.
now what is
60 divided by 2
well 60 divided by 2 is fairly
straightforward 6 divided by 2 is 3 so
60 divided by 2 is going to be equal to
30.
so that's 30 and so we're done now
another strategy is you could have
thought of all of these numbers in terms
of tenths you could have said this is
six i'm doing that orange color
you could have said this is six
tenths
divided by
divided by
or let me be careful this is 60 tenths
6 is 60 tenths
60 tenths
divided by
2 tenths
2
[Music]
tenths
is equal to
well i have 60 of something and if i
were to divide it into groups of two of
that something i would have 30 groups
that's going to be equal to 30.
let's do another example
this will be our most involved one
before we really try to show you the the
standard way of dividing decimals
let's say we wanted to compute
4.2 or 4 and 2 tenths
divided by
3 tenths
pause the video and see if you can
figure that out
well you've already seen multiple
techniques for tackling this it never
hurts to try to write this as a fraction
so this you could write as 4.2
divided by
3
tenths
and now we could try to get rid of the
decimals now the best way to do that i
could imagine i have 10c i have 10c if i
multiply the numerator and denominator
by 10
that might help out a lot because in the
numerator
this would move the decimal one to the
right so the numerator i would get 42
4.2 times 10 is 42
over
3 10 times 10
well that is going to be equal to 3.
and so what is 42 divided by 3
well there's multiple ways to do that
you could try to do it in your head or
you just try to actually do a little bit
of
medium long division it shouldn't be too
long
so let's see three goes into four one
time one times three is three
subtract
four minus three is oh why did i write
43 i knew something was fishy 42
3 goes into 42 my brain is
malfunctioning all right 3 goes into 4 1
time 1 times 3 is 3 you subtract 4 minus
3 is 1 bring down the 2 3 goes into 12 4
times so this is equal to
14. and so this one right over here is
going to be equal to 14. and just like
we saw in the last example you could
also think of this as 42 tenths
42 tenths divided by 3 tenths
divided by
three
tenths in which case 42 tenths 42 of
something divided into groups of three
of that something you're going to end up
with 14 groups
that you're going to end up with 14. so
hopefully you appreciate these ideas
express it as a fraction see if you can
multiply the numerator and denominator
by the same value so maybe the decimals
get eliminated
maybe you can think of these numbers in
terms of tenths or hundredths and then
think of it that way and any of these
combinations are going to be effective
strategies or hopefully expected
strategies for dividing decimals or
dividing numbers where the quotient
might be a decimal and in future videos
we're going to learn a more standard
systematic way of doing it but this is
always valuable you'll see i still if
someone walked up to me on the street
and said what's 4.2 divided by
0.3 this is how i would actually do it i
would say okay that's the same thing as
42 divided by 3
and then i would say okay 3 goes into 42
let's see 3 times 3 times 10 is 30 and
then 3 times 4 is 12 yeah that would be
14 times that's how my brain would do it
if i was trying to do it in my head